yeah so so comments has long embraced
the stakeholder model and recognizing
the importance of not only serving our
customers our investors also our
communities and our employees and so we
actually embrace Challenge and use that
challenge to drive Innovation and growth
we've done that historically as we've
reduced emissions from diesel engines
and we're really approaching the need to
decarbonize uh in a similar way we we
believe that for our industry that is so
both uh economically vital and needs to
be changed in a way that works for the
economy and also get to zero CO2
emissions that we do need to start
investing and advancing technologies
that get us all the way to zero and we
are doing that in our new power business
with battery electric and Fuel Cell
electric and green hydrogen Technologies
and we also believe that diesel engines
play an important role because we have
to start today
we can't wait uh our products get used
for decades and so we must derive
reductions in engine-based Solutions as
well as develop these diverse solutions
that will serve our applications and get
all the way to zero
great well let's let's come to Jillian
now and Jillian you've spent you know
you've had a career writing about And
discussing uh the role that corporations
play in climate change so from your
perspective like what do you think the
state of play is now when it comes to
corporations and sustainability goals
you know is it really happening and what
how much you know what should be
happening next
well it's worth stepping back for a
moment and saying that I first crashed
into this world
um shortly after the election of Donald
Trump when most journalists thought that
the only thing that really mattered that
was real news in America where I'm based
was um Trump trump and Trump and I
noticed I kept getting a lot of emails
in my inbox from companies and their PRS
talking about this thing called ESG
environmental social and governance and
sustainability
um and I deleted most of them for the
first few months because you know most
journalists are trained to think that
when companies start talking about doing
good and sustainability they're
basically doing a whole bunch of you
know corporate spin or PR Spin and
trying to bamboozle journalists
um and then after a few months I
realized I thought I started listening
to the companies and concerned and the
financiers and realized actually there
was a shift in mentality going on a
Zeitgeist shift which was really about
companies trying to redefine themselves
to have a sense of purpose
financiers trying to explain what impact
on the world the chase for profits was
actually having and also governments
running out of money to do their
development objectives and needing to
either use philanthropic cash or
corporate cash to get things done and
that was coming together to drive this
whole ESG movement to drive a
sustainability and most critically it
was driven by three things there were
three buckets of motives
um a tiny minority of companies were
doing it because they genuinely wanted
to change the world or investors and
those were people who were doing impact
investing they tend to tended to be sort
of Scandal then Pension funds and
Wealthy trust fund kids with a
conscience and stuff
um and then you had a bigger pool of
investors who wanted to do no harm to
the world and that was really what I
call the sustainability crew and then
you had an even bigger group of
companies and this is the key point but
really starting in about 2017-2018
wanted to avoid doing harm to themselves
because they'd realize that if they were
essentially seen to be polluting the
world they were in danger of losing
customers employees investors having
regulatory fines and reputational damage
so the whole drive towards environmental
issues and sustainability had flipped
from being something that was just kind
of in the doing good bucket in one tiny
Department of the company that have
become a key component of risk
management
and that really changed the whole debate
I guess that's really it's really
interesting from the point of view I
mean it's perhaps um encouraging from
the point of view of listeners who might
kind of feel helpless you know they're
just people out in the world that
actually public pressure does have an
effect on those things so perhaps that's
a note of optimism there and let's just
so we've we've gone around everyone to
get a a rounded picture of of who we've
got here let's come to Jason uh board
off now so Jason your your thing is
energy policy and and critically policy
is is not you know it the politics is
built into it right
um so how what's the interaction between
governments and corporations like in
this space like is it are they working
together at the moment and how do we
measure success
well I think ultimately we measure
success by whether emissions start going
down and so by that metric we're failing
we should remember other than a
recession or a pandemic emissions are
going up each and every year there are
some promising indicators that tell us
that might change going forward in most
recent annual Outlook that the
International Energy agency produces the
one that just came out a few weeks ago
this is the first time ever
in their Outlook that they find that
fossil fuel use peaks in the Outlook but
bear in mind the current Outlook is to
Peak and Plateau not fall at the rate
that would be necessary to come anywhere
close to climate goals like Net Zero by
2050 and to get there we're going to
need both government uh and and of
course the private sector I run
something as you said the center on
global energy policy with the word
policy in its name and have spent my
career working in policy because I think
it's necessary not sufficient but but
necessary to get to those goals and it
shapes the playing field uh on in which
companies um financial institutions
corporations make their decisions the
energy transition
needs a whole of society buy-in it's not
going to work if Government and
corporations have an adversarial
relationship and and both have a role to
play we need somewhere in the order of
three to four trillion dollars a year of
investment going into clean energy
between now and 2050 to take a goal like
Net Zero seriously most of that will be
private Capital there's just not enough
public Capital uh to fund the transition
private Capital can point it in a
certain direction it can de-risk certain
new technologies or regions of the world
that can catalyze
private Capital the same with the
technologies that we're going to need
somewhere around half of the cumulative
emission reductions between now and 2050
and those Net Zero scenarios come from
technologies that are not yet available
at commercial scale we need to bring the
cost of those Technologies down in
government investment in early stage
Technologies in r d research and
development can help do that so the
private sector can then step in and and
take it from there
did in something that you know that what
the big recent news in this area has
been the inflation reduction act uh the
IRA which still feels strange for a
British person to say but
um so this has been the big policy move
in the past few months um is this going
to do the job from your point of view
Jason then we'll come to
um Jillian and Jen but so is you know is
this enough and is it going to work
well it's certainly not enough but it is
a very significant step forward and it
is the by far the largest investment in
clean energy in U.S history
um there's a range of projections out
there and you should take them all with
a rather large grain of salt but the U.S
commitment is to reduce emissions around
50 by 2030 and a range of modeling
estimates show this will get us around
40 percent so there's more work to do
but but it makes a big step in in the
right direction there are a lot of
challenges to implementation and I think
that needs to be the focus now for for
all countries not just the US that is
one thing that I don't think emerged as
strongly as it could have or should have
from the UN climate talks in Egypt is
now
taking the pledges and targets and the
ambition that came out of recent climate
talks whether it's in Paris or Glasgow
and and implementation let's actually
make sure that we're doing what we said
we would do and in the US that's going
to be difficult I mean you look at some
of the
assumptions built into the modeling
those numbers I just gave forty percent
fifty percent it assumes the inflation
reduction spending again nearly 400
billion dollars in spending is able to
increase Renewables at a rate that would
more than double the renewable capacity
in the US by 2030. that requires a lot
more transmission uh it's really hard to
build things it's hard to get permitting
it's hard to get approvals we're going
to need to reform our processes here the
way Europe is trying to do with repower
EU not just because of climate but also
now in energy security challenge we've
seen a European backlash to the
inflation reduction act because there
are elements of protectionism in it
there are elements of industrial policy
which says if you want the tax credits
you have to make sure certain activity
is done in the US or sometimes Free
Trade Agreement countries so I can go on
the list there's a range of
implementation challenges but the focus
now really has to be putting that money
to work and making sure that between now
and 2030 we can scale clean energy at a
rapid rate because it has come down and
cost a lot solar batteries they're all
much much cheaper now let's get them out
there